مصادر الطاقه لا تنضب واراضي شاسعه ينعم
فيها خصوم واشنطن بالحريه
ليبيا البلد الذي يختزل كل اطماع الدول
تغيب فيه سفاره امريكيه عقود مرت وسياسه
واشنطن لا تزال تدير ظهرها لافريقيا ولن
تكفي الاراده السياسيه والخطابات لعودتها
الواقع شيء اخر
القاره اصابتها عدوى الاقتصاد الصيني
ومتلازمه فاجنر التي ارهقت فرنسا في مناطق
نفوذها التاريخيه عوده واشنطن تحتاج الى
خطه والكثير من الوقت
10 سنوات كامله ستمضيها واشنطن في اعاده
ترتيب خريطه النفوذ حسب اهوائها البدايه
من ليبيا ثم موزمبيق وغينيا الجديده وفي
غرب القاره وقع الخيار على بنين وكوت
ديفوار وغانا
اداره بايدن حددت ليبيا لتكون بوابه
العوده وهي التي اغلق دبلوماسيوها سفارتهم
فيها قبل عشر سنوات
النيه الان موجوده لكن التنفيذ تحد اخر لا
يمكنني اعطاء جدول زمني لكننا نعمل على
اعاده فتح سفاراتنا في ليبيا بنشاط وانا
مثلك تماما اطمحوا لاعاده تاسيس وجود
مستمر لنا في ليبيا ماذا عن تفاصيل الخطه
اولا دعم الشعب الليبي حتى يتمكن من
ممارسه حقه في انتخاب ممثليه وفي سبيل ذلك
كل اساليب الضغط الامريكيه مباحه قياده
وجيش واحد لبلد موحد لكن الجهود في
البدايه استفردت بالجنوب الليبي وهو
النقطه المحوريه في الخطه
وفقط بعد ظهور النتائج تعمم التجربه على
بقيه مناطق البلاد ومنها دول الساحل وغرب
افريقيا
المشروع استفاد من دعم الحزبين ومن خلاله
تعتزم امريكا بناء وجود دائم وقوي في
افريقيا
المبادره رفعت شعار حل الازمه الليبيه
لكنها قد تخفي اطماعا في خيرات البلاد او
حتى صراع نفوذ لا ينقص اراضي ليبيا الا ان
تحتضن احد فصوله